la amazonía no está el margen de las
campañas políticas en Brasil los
brasileños decidirán sobre dos programas
medioambientales divergentes el 30 de
octubre entre el del actual mandatario
ultraderechista Yair bolsonaro y el de
la izquierda Luis Ignacio lulada Silva
la selva amazónica abarca pocas líneas
del programa del presidente
sus políticas se centran en el papel del
ejército y la policía para combatir la
deforestación y los incendios forestales
el año pasado la destrucción en la selva
amazónica alcanzó el nivel más alto
desde 2006 según inpe unas cifras que
contrastan con las afirmaciones de
bolsonaro incluso frente a la ONU en la
amazonía brasileña un área equivalente a
Europa occidental más del 80% de la
selva permanece intacta contrariamente
lo que informan los principales medios
de comunicación nacionales e
internacionales
las promesas de campaña de Lula recalcan
en la necesidad de protección de la
amazonía y asegura que de tener un
tercer mandato llevará 0 las cifras de
deforestación
es necesario tener más gobiernos
globales y más fuertes una ONU y
fortalecida con la participación de los
países y con poder de decisión
concretamente en el tema climático ya
que si no lo tuviéramos vamos a dar un
discurso que no se cumplirá
durante su último mandato la
deforestación se redujo en un 72%. sin
embargo el expresidente promovió La
Represa hidroeléctrica develo monte en
el Amazonas causando perjuicio en sus
hábitats fluviales para los expertos la
deforestación es un problema histórico
en Brasil
la deforestación no comenzó en el
gobierno de bolsonaro la deforestación
comenzó en 2013 aún durante el gobierno
del partido de los trabajadores creció
Durante los años siguientes en una
secuencia muy clara y ahora alcanza un
récord en muchos años bajo el gobierno
de bolsonaro El próximo mandatario
tendrá el reto de revertir o prolongar
dicha situación